[Musique]
il n'y a pas à dire la chanteuse angèle
connu une période qui lui sourit sur un
plan professionnel depuis deux ans ses
tubes se classe numéro 1 ses concerts
affichent complet et ses choix
artistiques semble convaincre de
nombreux francophones qui adhèrent à
l'univers aussi libre que dans cent de
la jeune belge de 23 ans laisse moi te
viendront
[Musique]
mais ce bonheur parfait aurait pu être
gâché par une rupture sentimentale
en effet après deux ans de relation la
star a connu une séparation difficile
avec léo walk un danseur et créateurs
que le succès soudain de la carrière de
la chanteuse n'aura pas épargné une
rupture dont elle parle dans le morceau
perdu extrait de la réédition de son
dernier album
ces derniers mois j'ai flanché longue
date aux alentours
sans prendre la meuse et
mais aujourd'hui tout semble aller pour
le mieux d'après le magazine public
angèle serait aujourd'hui de nouveau en
couple si dans ses chansons elle avait
déjà fait des sous-entendus sur ses
préférences sexuelles qui est pensée
parfois je ne voulais pas le voir je
l'avais chantait déjà mais sans trop le
savoir les échecs me font peur je joue
avec le roller après mon coeur
j'y ai pensé en bout
play
c'est donc aujourd'hui avec une femme
qu'elle semble couler des jours heureux
au bras de marie une jeune youtube euse
la chanteuse s'affiche plus souriante
que jamais belle histoire qui devrait
avoir le temps de s'installer après la
tournée chargée qui est sur le point de
terminer angèle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
oui jean michel je suis juste étonnée
que qui bavaient sur la presse people
mais quand y avait des images et
regarder tout cela
vous savez je suis fan de géraldine
maillet un des vrais c'est ce que disait
si l'entente a du mal a dit un truc qui
joue dessus et c'est pas vrai alors à la
raison par exemple à là c'est pas alors
je sais pas si c'est vrai ou si c'est
faux c'était une bombe alors pas rentrer
là dedans oui à une photo mais ça veut
rien dire dans la rue avec quelqu'un
s'en est avec la personne maintenant
j'en passe maintenant à elles se sont
passées chez palm os peuvent dollars us
en 2009 on dire oui je trouve qu'elle a
un talent exceptionnel et la meilleure
mais cela mais en ce moment c'est la
meilleure et savait qu'on lui souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur voilà et la claque
en tout cas